allez un coup de chapeau maintenant à
nos confrères de france bleu isère
d'après un sondage médiamétrie du mois
dernier
les audiences de france bleu sont en
augmentation et bat même des records
nous sommes donc rendus dans les
coulisses de france bleu isère très tôt
le matin
c'est un reportage de claire schaffner
et franck ceroni bientôt 5h30 grenoble
dort encore à la rédaction de france
bleu
les matinalier ont déjà les yeux rivés
sur leur ordinateur dans l'actualité ce
matin les précipitations
c'est au bord de la ssi à cette heure on
apprend qu'il ya plus un train qui
circule que l'auto sera toujours
attendre ok mais c'est plutôt voilà
alors je préfère ça parce que tu te
réveilles tu es chez toi en temps ça
mais là les gens ça les stresse pas
lionel prépare son premier journal
depuis 3h du matin ses taux mais c'est
l'horaire ou la radio et le plus écouté
c'est un bon moyen la radio pour les
gens de savoir si loin dans la
difficulté aujourd'hui connaître les
bons plans les astuces etc pour déplacer
mon club pour le coup de matinée comme
celle ci c'est assez intéressant ça va
évoluer
pas mal voilà d'accord auquel aux
derniers coups de fil aux pompiers au
revoir et c'est déjà l'heure de prendre
l'antenne trois heures de direct où se
succèdent aux flashs jeu et inforoute et
derrière le micro c'est jérôme qui anime
toujours avec le sourire
on est super concentré parce que oui il
faut respecter le timing faut faire
attention d'ailleurs l'âge écoute d'une
oreille parce que ça va bientôt être la
fin du disque et qu'il va falloir passer
à la suite mais est on voit pas le temps
passer la matinale ces trois heures mais
ça défile hyper vite vous aimez ça moi
j'adore fauteuil que les auditeurs aussi
participants l'accessibilité à bientôt
véronique au revoir
et c'est peut-être ça la recette du
succès de france bleu on ne peut pas se
permettre de dire la moindre bêtise
parce que vous êtes sûr que vous faites
chauffer le standaard
dans la minute qui suit si vous avez
écorché le nom de communes si vous avez
écorché un nom d'une personnalité locale
qui est connu donc voilà on est vraiment
dans cette proximité moi j'aime beaucoup
ça que j'aime beaucoup rêver les gens il
est 9 heures c'est la fin de la matinale
d'autres journalistes sont déjà en
studio pour une nouvelle tranche
[Musique]